Seth Rogen is receiving a lot of praise
online after he responded to Instagram
followers who were criticizing his
blacklivesmatter post Rogen posted this
to Instagram with the caption if this is
a remotely controversial statement to
you
feel free to unfollow me that post
currently has over 400,000 likes but
many of his 8 million followers
disagreed but Seth wasn't having any of
it
the knocked-up star definitely didn't
hold back when it came down to shutting
down certain comments he shared a bunch
of his blunt responses primarily using
the f-word for example here's one one
user wrote why do all of these brutality
videos only show the end they don't show
WTF these people were doing to get in
trouble in the first place - which Seth
responded with this f off you don't
deserve my movies anymore stop watching
my ass someone else wrote all lives
matter we all bleed red facts the actor
replied f off facts and another user
wrote all lives matter because all life
is precious no life is more important
than another Rogen responded with shut
the F up Seth was trending on Twitter
with many people reposting his responses
at Monroe Shelley shared some of them
with this caption I love Seth Rogen's
approach to racists now that tweet has
over 300,000 likes at each Sawyer also
reposted his responses to Twitter with
this caption Seth Rogen explaining it in
the simplest way possible
now that tweet has over 600,000 likes on
Twitter and asked father Elms simply
wrote Seth Rogen for president
Billy Eilish also made headlines
recently after she spoke out in support
of black lives matter and taking issue
with though
using the all lives matter cause here's
part of the message she shared to
Instagram if I hear one more white
person say all lives matter
one more effing time I'm gonna lose my
effing mind no one is saying your life
doesn't matter no one is saying your
life is not hard this is not about you
stop making everything about you you are
not in need you are not in danger now
her message inspired others like pink
who shared a part of Billie's post to
her Instagram but similar to Seth some
of Pink's almost 8 million followers
disagree with one person writing totally
get where you're coming from however as
a person with a lawyer brain I have to
say when you single at one race and say
that race matters you are implicitly
saying other races don't matter as much
it is automatically inferred to which
pink replied with this you are the
epitome of white privilege and the
saddest part is that you don't even hear
yourself and probably never will a lot
of other celebrities are supporting the
black lives matter movement including
Harry Styles who posted the same graphic
except with this caption I do things
every day without fear because I am
privileged in that privilege every day
because I'm white being not racist is
not enough we must be anti-racist social
change is enacted when a society
mobilizes I stand in solidarity with all
of those protesting I'm donating to help
post bail for arrested organizers look
inwards educate yourself and others so
what do you think about Seth Rogen's
post and his lunch responses to his
followers let me know in the comments
below